[Music]
hello welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a podcast where me Hank
and my brother John tell you stuff about
ourselves answer your questions give you
dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how you doing John I'm doing
really well you might remember that last
week I expressed concern that the sort
of post Taylor Swift Indianapolis
weather might be fading Taylor Swift
came to town several weeks ago and
brought with her the most beautiful
weather the city of Indianapolis has
ever seen but somehow her memory it was
large and we've had yet another
astonishingly beautiful beautiful early
fall week I'm writing every day outside
walking down to the White River and
sitting in a chair down by the White
River and writing my news story and it
just it couldn't be better that sounds
lovely
how are you I'm good I'm busy nerdcon as
of the recording of this podcast is
several days away by the time it goes
online it will have happened and so I
can't tell you how it went but but maybe
I will say something about that on
Twitter or on my snapchat Hank GRE on
snapchat I mean the hardest working
snapchat promo game in the world so I'm
literally about to get on a plane to go
to Minneapolis I was working all night
on wizard school Kickstarter stuff not
all night but a lot and then and then in
my off time I've been listening to
podcast reading books and and watching
the Americans have you seen this Joe Jon
Oh have I seen that show in fact the
reason you're watching it is because I
have recommended it to you that's not
true I first started watching because
Michael Gardner and Colin recommended it
to me they kept talking about it in the
office and I was like that looks like
fun and I can't do it what do you think
of it it's great oh it's so great it's
so great
oh that shows good television
programming it is candy for people of my
generation yeah totally
you know they give me the cars of my
childhood they give me the two great
empires battling each other in quiet and
secret of my childhood everything that
was great and terrible about my
childhood is contained inside that show
and also it is the best television
program I have ever seen about marriage
about real people being actually married
it is such a good marriage show yeah I
was remarkably good yeah John you know I
remember asking mom once when I was like
like six saying when did the Cold War
end and mom being like oh no honey
that's still happening ya know the Cold
War lasted until uh you know until I was
about 12 years old with the fall of the
Berlin Wall
although in some ways I mean you would
you could argue that the Cold War
continues I mean we continue to have
indeed these proxy wars between the
United States and Russia we had them you
know in the 80s in Afghanistan and then
here we are 30 years later you know
having having two heavily armed groups
heavily funded by the United States and
Russia fighting in Syria so yeah I don't
know we still seem to not get along that
well with Russia despite all of our best
attempts indeed John do you have a short
poem for us I do okay how great is the
Americans I mean I it might be the best
show I've ever seen on TV
oh let's but right but we can move on
though right I guess I'm why don't we
have a why don't we have an Americans
recap podcast can't believe all right I
would need to get cable today's short
poem is called a discoveries in Arizona
by James Wright all right as one of
those little notes from the author
before the poem thank you I don't know
if you know those notes but the note is
all my life so far I have been afraid of
cactus spiders rattlesnakes the tall 14
year old boy who led me through the
desert whispered come over this way
picking my steps carefully over an earth
strangely familiar I found four small
holes large enough for a root
that might have been torn out or a black
snake hole in Ohio that I hated what is
it I said some cute prairie dog or an
abandoned post hole maybe no he said
she's down there with her children she
doesn't hate you she's not afraid she's
probably asleep she's probably keeping
warm with something I don't know about
and all I know is sometimes in sunlight
to brown legs reach out it is hard to
get a look at her face even in the
museum she turns away I don't know where
she's looking I have lived all my life
in terror of a tarantula and yet I have
never even seen a tarantula turn her
face away from me that's all right said
the boy
maybe she's never seen you either
discoveries in Arizona by James Wright a
bit of a longer short poem for today
Hank but I thought you might like it
because it's got some nature in it I
know that your pro nature you're right I
did like it it gave me goosebumps oh wow
it's a massive victory well if you
thought that was exciting wait till the
news from AFC Wimbledon well before we
do that we have about 40 minutes of
talking about people's problems how does
that sound yes but it will be cut down
to 20 um all right this question comes
from Maddie she writes dear John and
Hank I am wondering about YouTube ads do
I have to watch the whole thing for the
creator to benefit also if I'm watching
an ad for a product or company I don't
support but a channel that I do want to
support what should I do
would it even make a difference if I
skip the ad great question Maddie and
one near and dear to our hearts as
YouTube creators how did you know I know
a ridiculous amount about this topic and
no one knows how much of an ad on
YouTube you need to watch before the
creator gets paid that is a that is a
secret that no one knows the answer to
but if you skip it immediately the
Creator does not get paid if you watch
an advertisement for a product that you
dislike or a service or a political
candidate that you do not like that
isn't bad that isn't good for the
service or the candidate or whatever
that's actually only good for the
creator and it's actually kind of bad
for the product or service
because they're paying to have you look
at that and it is not affecting you in
the way that they would like to affect
to you so if so just say through those
awful terrible terrifying don't actually
do that no because advertising is a
terrible way to support creators and
it's that is not the reason you should
be watching ads yeah my response here
would be to value your time and yes and
if that means watching an ad because
you're interested in it and it seems
like a good use of your time then that's
fine if it if it doesn't you shouldn't
feel a responsibility to watch an
advertisement to support a YouTube
creator because in my opinion at least
like it's just an incredibly inefficient
way to support the YouTube creator like
I would probably be better off with you
sending me a dollar every six months oh
nothing with you watching you would be
better off with them sending you a
dollar every three years right I would
be better off I'm really bad at math
Maddy I apologize I would be better off
with you sending me one dollar every
three years than with you watching an ad
on every single video that I make so
save that dollar save your time of not
watching ads maybe do some do some work
don't try to get five minutes and work
at Starbucks or something and then send
me that dollar yeah I mean well this is
or this is something that Hank and I
kind of worried and thought a lot about
because it used to be that most of our
income came from or a lot of our income
came from ads but we've found that it's
just such an inefficient way to support
YouTube creators and it ultimately like
it introduces you know someone into the
conversation who I don't really want to
be in the conversation and so we've
found other ways to to make a living and
now all the ad revenue from vlogbrothers
just goes to support educational
projects into the charity the foundation
or decrease worldsuck so but even then I
don't think it's quote unquote worth it
to your time to watch an ad unless you
want to so if you want to support a
YouTube creator buy their things buy a
shirt buy a poster buy a book buy that
that's the way to do it and you get a
thing so that's good we've got another
question
one is from Paulina who says here's one
for the dubious advice it's probably she
meant to say dear Hank and John here's
one for the dubious advice do you think
it's okay for a college aid to her
otherwise adult person to sleep with a
stuffed animal
she's got got an attachment to a loved
bear yeah named long-nosed yes and
here's the important part I still feel
like I have to have him with me but I
don't want anyone to see him and be
creeped out or think I'm immature or
something do you have any dubious advice
I'm gonna be totally honest with you
Paulina from where I sit in my chair
right now as a 35 year old man
podcasting I can reach out and touch my
childhood sleep animal Dexter the
black-footed ferrets so I'm gonna be a
yes on this one I am also a yes also I'm
a huge fan of Dexter the black-footed
ferret I remember the Christmas that he
came into our lives and he just I do too
yeah he became part of our family
um it was really you know my mom my dad
my brother are terrible dog red/green
myself and Dexter the black-footed
ferret and and yeah I mean I guess I
would say that anybody anybody who
judges you for whatever thing you do to
find comfort and warmth in this world
that isn't illegal and doesn't hurt
anybody that that says more about them
than it says about you yeah I think
being an adult is is whatever you want
it to be and and a lot of it is being
confident in being able to make those
kinds of decisions and do the kinds of
things that aren't things that people
would expect or that seemed like adult
things to do and that's like one of the
greatest parts of being an adult and
having that confidence and security is
difficult to come by but you should try
and embrace it when you can get it and
and I will say that the thing that you
are find the object that you were
finding enjoyable and that might be
bringing you comfort or security or
whatever is a lot less silly than some
of the other objects that people enjoy
that bring them security and happen to
cost tens over hundreds of thousands of
dollars so I think we've got another
question this one is from a proper adult
who writes Dear John and Hank I would
like your advice on
17 year old daughter she wakes at 3 or 4
in the afternoon
reaches for the Internet and remains on
it until 3 or 4 the following morning
she neglects her studies spends her time
watching you to the point where she
knows the ornaments on your shelf advice
question mark yours concerned London
father well concerned London father I I
appreciate that you are concerned in
this situation and I think that your
concern is real and legitimate but I
want to begin by asking you a question a
question that is very important to me
which is are you going to the AFC
wimbledon game this Saturday because
you're in London you have every
opportunity to do so and let me also
encourage you to bring your daughter to
that game because it's a wonderful way
to bond and the thrill of fourth tier
English football will make it absolutely
impossible for her to look at her phone
so that's where I think we should start
oh man I yeah I mean you first start at
the point of believing that the thing
that the person you love is into is
legitimate and then work back from there
and and worry about not what they are
spending their time doing but what they
are not spending their time doing so if
this question had said had said my
daughter's having a hard time sleeping
and this is neglecting her studies that
is the exact same thing I'm reading here
what she's doing instead of that is like
I I assume either something that she
very much enjoys or something that or or
that she has just like you know she's in
a funk she's in a bad place and she
needs to you know she needs support and
she needs love in in a difficult time in
her life I agree but I think that the
real key here is to make sure that you
get to King's meadow on Saturday
afternoon 3 p.m. oh yeah you know John
I'm glad I'm glad that I'm not and never
was a teenage girl
it sounds like hard work well I don't I
don't recall being a teenage boy being
particularly easy no agreed agreed but I
think that it in the end might be easier
yeah I mean it well it there
no question that in general you know
there are all kinds of structural
privileges for men but yeah but I I
greatly disliked being a teenager or I
guess I wouldn't say I simply disliked
it I just found it tremendously
difficult and stressful and scary and
overwhelming and I had no idea what I
was doing there's a great line from a
sociologist I think his name is Clifford
Geertz but I apologize if it's not
anyway he wrote the difference between
dogs and people is that dogs know how to
be dogs and I was 16 more than anything
else I felt that I was a person who had
no idea how to be a person I feel yeah I
still don't really know how to be a
person I basically just do whatever
comes across my plate that is exactly
the same approach to life that dogs take
all right I did it John I figured out
how to be a person all right we got
another question this one is from
Stephanie I hope that was helpful
concerned London father I feel a little
bit like we belittled your position but
you know no I'm not trying to belittle
the position at all I would I would just
say that like the the concerns are real
the concern of you know neglecting your
studies feeling disengaged from your
family and your life like those are big
problems not sleeping enough that's a
big problem the problem I would argue
though is not is not the internet I
don't think the internet is causing
those problems so I think the key is
just gonna be to try to find a way to
engage with your daughter like for
instance taking her to the book okay
this question not backing down off my
advice because I like rare cases where
my advice is excellent well everybody
else who's listening in London you got
to get your get yourself out to the
pitch and watch the game not only that
Hank but you can join the Dons trust and
become an owner of AFC Wimbledon for
like if you are if you are a student for
like 20 bucks for like 15 pounds
all right anyway today's podcast is
brought by AFC Wimbledon AFC Wimbledon
the greatest football club in the
history of the world and also the
solution to all your problems
today's podcast is brought to you by
Dexter the black-footed ferret a
representative of a severely imperiled
group of individuals that I'm sure was
purchased by my enviro crazy dad in some
way that was supportive of that inbred
group of pop individuals who were
decimated but have come back despite the
fact that their entire food supply of
prairie dogs was killed by farmers and
of course today's podcast was brought to
you by Hanks freaking snapchat Hank gr e
on snapchat the future of social media
there's a lot of my dog you'll see a lot
of my dog boy Hank let's have another
question this one comes from Stephanie
who writes Dear John and Hank a few
months ago my boyfriend and I moved into
a house together in a very quiet village
we're both twenty-something and all our
neighbors are 50 plus we've met them a
few times in passing and they seemed
very friendly but I worried that they
consider us to be inherently unlike
aboard that they disapprove of us living
in a primarily retired area when we are
in our prime as it were I'll try not to
take that personally Stephanie not any
advice for becoming better friends with
your neighbors particularly with older
neighbors who may disapprove of you
without any real reason oh I oh you
don't know for sure that they disapprove
of you Stephanie that's the first thing
that I'd say like it's possible that you
feel this generation gap that they don't
feel and that like some of the
awkwardness just comes from you thinking
of them as like other which of course
they are because they've been alive more
than twice as long as you have but but I
think like the thing that breaks down
that gap to me is spending time together
so I would just try to like invite them
over for coffee or tea or whatever you
do in your country yeah first I'll say
that I'm just shocked that you're
interested at this like when I don't
know I feel like most young people
probably wouldn't be like oh how do I
make my 58 year old neighbor like me
that's how do you think that that's
weird John or is that am I crazy no I
think it's good news though if we can
live in a world where people want to
actually have social engagement with
their neighbors I think that's great
yeah
so so I'll say that you took a good
first step and one thing to have this be
the case and I encourage other people to
know who their neighbors are but yeah I
think that I wouldn't say that there's I
wouldn't guess that there's dislike but
I would think that there's just like you
know we're not gonna have so much in
common and so we're gonna hang out with
all of the people around us who we know
and and have stuff in common with us but
I will say that I have some really
rewarding relationships with people who
are you know more than 30 years older
than me and and is really cool to be
able to have those relationships because
that kind of diversity of perspectives
and worldviews is really informative and
interesting I totally agree Hank as I
usually do we don't have enough fighting
on this podcast we need to find things
that we disagree about speaking of which
we have a question from Aaron who writes
Dear John and Hank when is it
appropriate to get into an argument on
the Internet or otherwise what is worth
fighting god bless you Aaron for yeah
for even asking that question instead of
just getting into a fight on the
internet which is what everyone else is
doing right well maybe we should get in
a fight about this question John but
we'll probably will agree I will say
that that often times people say that
the the reason you argue on the internet
isn't about convincing the person you're
arguing with it's about convincing the
bystanders and that is bull that's just
a bunch of honky and I am like when I
see that argument I'm like it makes me
cringe so hard because like what you're
saying is like that your argument like
is this thing that that like that
there's it's like a spectator sport like
internet arguments public performance
yeah and I and to me like the the
argument as public performance is such
an evil kind of an evil way to think
about public discourse which is what
we're talking about and and when you
should argue on the Internet the only
reason you should argue on the Internet
is if you come out of the argument with
a more nuanced view of the world and a
better appreciation of the perspective
and the values of the person you were
arguing with in other words never like
you it's like that's what you should be
aiming for
and that's never what's happening yeah I
mean I think you should argue on the
internet if you can do so respectfully
and thoughtfully and like Hank said like
emerge from it with a more nuanced
understanding of the world around you
which is very very rare but I don't
think that it's impossible and I don't
quite think that it's never because I I
for one for many many years like I felt
that the critique around work that Hank
and I did was just incredibly generous
and and thoughtful but at the same time
like you know wasn't like a bunch of
people just agreeing with us to agree
with us like lots of when we would we
would be wrong at times and it would be
pointed out to us in ways that were
respectful and thoughtful and then I
think when we were at our best at least
or when we are at our best at least like
we can we can listen to that internalize
it and and change and I do think that
can happen in online discourse I have
seen it in my own life I know that it is
rare I know that the quality of
conversation online is notoriously poor
and and sometimes it's so bad that you
just have to remove yourself from the
conversation which frankly is what I've
felt like I've had to do and know in the
last few months and and and to be honest
I think my life is better for it but
like I don't believe that that there is
no good or interesting or critical
conversation happening online I agree I
agree but a sort of implicit in Aaron's
question is you know what is worth
fighting for like when you see something
that just it feels like that shall not
stand I must do something about this
yeah I mean I think there's a lot I
think there's a lot that's worth
fighting for but I don't think that the
right way to have the fight is to scream
at people on the internet and try to
prove to them that they're wrong the
right way to have the fight is you know
in how you with your life and in your
values and in how you vote and in the
conversations that you have with people
who are willing to be open and listen
and
and when you are willing to be open and
list I agree we've you have another
question this one is from chanela who
says we speak a different language in
our house over time I've lost some of
that language and get by everyday only
through basic conversational phrases I
really like and value my relationship
with my parents but I find that I can't
always talk about different opinions and
complicated topics because I have
trouble explaining myself it feels like
I'm a different person with my friends
than I am at home where I somehow dumbed
down and can't express my personality
and thoughts people say that who you are
at home is more representative of your
actual identity do you agree how do I
show more of my personality at home and
can I have an honest relationship with
my parents I think that's really hard
what a great question we have such
interesting listeners yeah it's such an
interesting and I had a friend when I
was growing up who was in this situation
more with his grandparents than with his
parents who also lived in his house who
he was basically unable to communicate
with but that that is that is a it's a
it's a tension that I obviously never
had to deal with speaking one language
and and nothing else and and being
raised in a very homogenous little world
but you know there there is there is a
universality in some of this which is
which is like do you feel like you like
like what is your identity and and if
you lose that in your home life if you
sort of can't have that in your home
life like what does that mean for you
yeah I actually think that this would be
a good time to use our listeners and our
hashtags Hank because we're not going to
be able to give much direct advice here
but maybe a hashtag advice number for
chanela advice for Chanel sha and e la
could be a good source of advice because
I think we're not gonna have much direct
to say about this but I don't agree at
all that who you are at home is it needs
to be most representative of your actual
identity and also I mean there's
something inherent about the limits of
language for everyone that that sort of
circumscribed the way that we are able
to talk about our
elves and and express our you know
concerns and passions to other people
but that's far far more complicated when
you know you you don't have the the
skills in the language to do that with
the kind of nuance that you feel like
you need to so I think it would be a
really interesting thing to hear from
other listeners about who've maybe had
direct experience with it I agree with
you John we have one possibly one more
question and this one is from Toby who
asks dear Hank and John in meteorology
climate models predict future events
based on current conditions the models
are created in tuned using past weather
conditions however climate change will
begin or more likely has begun to change
the climate
so if pre climate change weather events
of an an area can no longer accurately
reflect current or future weather our
weather models will become inaccurate so
my question is will we no longer be able
to have forecasts what kind of economic
and sociological problems will this pose
tobe you this is such a minor problem on
the on the scale of climate change it is
a thing to be somewhat concerned with
especially when it comes to local
forecasts and local weather people who
know their local weather patterns and
sort of know what to expect and they
will potentially be wrong more often but
compared with say you know having to
build a wall around New York City or
like not having water fall on crops I'm
less worried about this particular
problem well but I think nor the larger
issue I think that Toby is talking about
is a concern about not just like being
able to have forecasts but forecasts
being very useful for not just like
people who like want to go to the beach
but farmers who need to understand yeah
you know what the what the rainfall
levels will likely be during certain
months of the year and the but the other
thing to note is that weather and
climate are very different things and it
is you know that the patterns that we
see that we can sort of understand in
terms of our you know in terms of like
forecasting you know
one or two or five days out those things
actually won't change like like high
pressure systems low pressure systems
like what those things bring what you
know cold fronts didn't like that
stuff's gonna like we'll be able to see
that coming we'll be able to do these
short-term predictions predicting
climate and predicting weather are very
very separate things so I'm actually I'm
not super concerned about this and
that's what predicting climate is really
important for farmers predicting weather
like no climate like the likelihood that
there will be like in certain years
because of larger climate patterns there
will be more rain or less rain in
certain seasons right like the rainy
season correct me if I'm wrong because I
am NOT a scientist but the rainy season
you know may may move in in Eastern
Africa depending on whether there's you
know the the right the temperature of
the ocean water is this or that yeah
whatever yeah I mean that's sort of an
in that seems like a big problem that's
an in-between II place that's a that's a
place in between what we would call like
I think meteorology versus climate
science so yeah I mean weather I mean
like the the atmosphere is a very
dynamic and changeable and weird thing
and and our understandings of it
generally generally reach out to like
two days from now in terms of actually
like like predictive science but but you
know larger larger weather patterns can
can't have these sort of like you know
you can sort of make a bet you know we
can bet one way or another and that is
that is a concern and I hadn't thought
about it so thank you to Toby for
bringing that up but Hank you are on
record as saying that you think that
climate change is going to be a fairly
big deal in the in the coming century I
am on record as saying that yes that is
a as a safe position I wanted to ask you
about some some stuff I've read recently
here's the biggest question that I have
do you think and and and again I don't
know much about climate science so I
might be way off here but do you think
there's any way that we could have
Taylor Swift Duke
there you know so that like after she
left there would be these like months of
joyous beautiful blue sky I think that'd
be a huge problem if if Taylor Swift did
simultaneous concerts everywhere and
then there was two months straight of
blue skies we would run out of water
real quick that would be called that
would be called the Swift dock ellipse
and and it would just
most people would die so you you would
be opposed I do like the idea though
because I'm trying to figure out like
maybe there's a different band that
brings rain the way that Taylor Taylor's
concert brought this incredibly
beautiful weather to Indianapolis and so
anyway I'm gonna I'm just gonna keep
just keep it in the back of your mind
because I know there's lots of different
approaches to what we're gonna do with
climate change I know that there's you
know lots of people working hard on lots
of solutions but I'm just saying this is
well we need more diverse diverse you
know roundup of musical acts that affect
the weather we need some people who who
make it warmer some people who make it
rain some people who make it cooler you
know so we yeah we need to and it seems
at least it appears that all all Taylor
can do is bring you know blue blue
cloudless skies and beautiful early fall
weather so we're gonna need someone who
can reliably deliver the rain I'm gonna
I'm gonna work on that
that'll be my project for the next few
weeks while you work on other solutions
to climate change should we move on to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
[Music]
hey John do you think it's time for the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon yes
although we should acknowledge that
what's happened is that Hank broke
something in his podcasting because he's
incompetent and I'm very competent and
I'm the good one and he's the fat one
and so we've had to do the news from the
glorious future where we are here
physically together at nerdcon stories
in Minneapolis Minnesota Hank what is
the news from Mars the news from Mars
let me see if I can remember what the
news from Mars was I actually do
remember was it nope I'm not gonna make
come before you but basically the news
from Mars was this amazing thing about
the Mars doesn't have a magnetic field
and that's why the atmosphere that was
once on Mars sort of blew away due to
solar winds after I do this you're gonna
do the news from AFC Wimbledon and what
we learned is that this may be because
Mars used to have this heavy metal core
and then magma and then a crust and that
sort of solid liquid solid vibe is what
allowed this magnetic field to exist but
now it's solid at least in parts all the
way down although there are parts of
Mars that are still Magnum - that
doesn't mean what I thought it meant
anyway so we're starting to try to
understand why that happened in the
hopes that we can eventually build a
Martian atmosphere maybe that doesn't
blow away and that's the news from Mars
those roughly he skipped a little step
which is that now there is no longer a
magnetic field because Mars is mostly
solid all the way through maybe you did
say that and I just misunderstood I did
say that I I nailed the news from Mars
what's the news from AFC Wimbledon
helped me do in our last couple games uh
you tied which one of them it was
against another team that's right and
that was a little disappointing yes but
then the other one but then the other
one you won what was the score I think
it was three one it was two new but you
got that you got to spread corrector and
and that means that AFC Wimbledon now
has a zero gold
which means that they've scored the same
number of goals that they have given up
that's right and they are solidly in the
middle of the pack of tier 2 tier 4 -
you're for English football Oh God can
you imagine the days when we might be a
second tier English Football Club Hank
glory the glory that awaits AFC
Wimbledon but yes we beat Barnet and
tide Northampton Town and rosianna house
house Barnet pronounced bonnet yeah like
bonnet like the thing you wear on your
heads we dominated bonnets we beat them
to nil and how do we say Northampton
Northampton oh okay that we're close on
that one yeah all right so that's the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon sorry
Hank's a podcasting equipment broke but
you know this wasn't bad I know in the
original one I had a great joke about
how if we just put Black Sabbath at the
center of Mars that was really good then
potentially we could have an atmosphere
on Mars again because it has the heavy
metal core yes right and then I made a
joke about about what's in their
mini-fridge yeah which it just was funny
in context but not really funny we
summarized it so with that with that
noted we are going to go ahead and end
the podcast thank you for listening you
can always write us your questions
comments concerns recommendations for
short poems at Hank and John at
gmail.com this podcast is edited by
nicholas jenkins who has been a real
trooper in getting this together
despite the fact that we're doing it
partially at nerdcon stories the theme
music is by gunnarolla and and maureen
johnson what do they say in our home
town oh don't forget to be awesome
that was great
you
[Music]